♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
YVONNE ORJI:
While I was getting my Master's,
I entered a pageant.
It was the Miss Nigeria
in America Pageant.
It's very specific,
Nigerian in America.
Two weeks before the pageant,
they called and asked
what my talent was.
Now, when you're a child
of immigrants,
you're not allowed
to have talents.
Your only talent is just
to get straight A's.
The only thing I knew to play
on the piano was
"Mary Had A Little Lamb"
and I just didn't think
that would cut it.
So I was like,
"God, I need a lifeline."
And loud as day,
I heard the voice of God say,
"Do comedy."
And I was like, "No.
'Cause what? Am I funny?"
And I heard the Holy Spirit say,
"What else do you have?"
And so I said, "I got nothing!"
And he's like,
"Well one day you're gonna
trust me or you're not."
I remember my first joke
was, um,
Nigerians don't know
how to whisper,
'cause anytime a call
comes from overseas,
it's always: "Hello?!
Can you hear me?
Yes, no. I'm hearing you,
but can you hear me?"
And I was turning to my mom
like,
"Mom, everyone can hear you,
'cause we're in church."
People laughed and then I was
like, "Am I actually funny,
not around other Africans?"
And then the best thing
happened.
There was a recession,
so nobody else had a job.
So I figured this could be
my only chance
to be poor
with the rest of America,
but be pursuing entertainment.
And so I moved to New York
to start comedy and acting.
When I saw the breakdown
for Molly on Insecure,
I jumped at it because it said,
"dark-skinned black woman
who's able to be both corporate
and slightly hood."
I was like, "I need to be her."
When I first met
the real-life Molly,
we were at a mutual friend's
birthday party and Issa's like,
"Oh, I gotta introduce you
to her." And so we go,
and we kind of look
at each other, we like hug,
then we're kind of going around
in a circle like,
"Oh my God! You have
big eyes too! She has big eyes!"
And then it's like,
we start like,
talking about each other's body
parts and then a song came on.
I started dancing,
she started dancing,
and we were like getting low
on the dance floor.
It's like,
"She can dance like me!"
It's so crazy because we had
never met prior to that,
we were just like, "Look at us,
we are twins,
we were meant to be."
And so, we posted the picture
with the hashtag
SheIsMe AndIAmHer.
And Issa's like, "I know,
I did well. Good casting."
(TV STATIC)